dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
インターネットの発展は言葉の進化より早い
よってひと言で表せないインターネット社会現象がたくさんありまた日本語には
四字熟語と言って多少複雑な現象4つな感じで表すっていう素晴らしいものがあるのに
それが現代の
炎症に使われることはほとんどない今日は新しい四字熟語をつくって現代の
インターネット社会現象を表してみたいと思う
一番いいねやコメントはたくさん残してくれるけど現実では交流をすべて川瀬1
通信忍者に板 sns と現実が別人に見える現象
液晶決勝3番求められていないのに自ら卑猥な写真送る男
判断範囲
4番インスターグラムのフォロワー増やすために胸を丸出しにする女
詳細タイガー5番人気カップルが小宅の s ですで激しく揉めて別れること
電気花火6番景色の写真にフィルターをつけすぎること
北斎妄想な版 facebook のプロフィール写真を変えることで世界の悲しい
君をなくそうとすることをすでに言葉があったんだ
自己満足8番撮影車
健くんという口実を使って自分の写りが良い写真をどんどんアップする女
好日芸者9番高いカメラを買って綺麗に撮ってあげたら女が自分に惚れると勘違いする
男
バカ剛10番スマホがないと充実した生活が
送れないという考え方悪魔の証11番
テレビに出るほどの才能がないから youtube で活動する人
me
ni